the last remnants of an Ice Age cling to
the poles of our planet an ice age
that's been receding for the last 11,000
years stepping foot here is like
stepping back in time to a world covered
in ice whipping winds and harsh
unsettling cold but on this wind whipped
ice stands a stoic creature a creature
who does not survive despite the ice but
depends on it hailed by many as the
Lords of Antarctica emperor penguins can
reach Heights of up to 1.3 M or 4.3 ft
and weigh up to 100 lb or 45 kg making
them the largest penguin species but
these massive Birds earn their name not
for their size but for their physical
characteristics and abilities that make
them seem as though they were designed
to truly rule the Antarctic and even
though their imagery pervades the media
compared to all other birds and and even
to other Penguins emperor penguins are
downright strange creatures no other
animal can survive the cold like they
can no other animal is so wonderfully
and bizarrely adapted to life on the ice
but also life in the sea the emperor
penguin is considered the deepest diving
bird in the world reaching depths far
beyond 500 M and capable of staying
under frigid waters for up to 30 minutes
at a time their feathers not only
streamline their swimming but can also
be actively manipulated to create an air
injection providing a hydrodynamic boost
we normally only see in high-tech ships
and underwater missiles and to keep warm
during their life in The Frigid sea and
windy sheets of ice they've evolved a
unique composition of feathers that
don't just retain their body heat but
actively draw in heat from an
environment that seems like it doesn't
have any they also utilize sea ice as a
breeding ground and if this wasn't
impressive enough they choose to use the
ice to breed in the harsh Antarctic
winter where temperatures can reach 50°
C below freezing the coldest breeding
temperature any known bird can tolerate
and despite all these incredible
adaptations we humans were certain for a
long time that emperor penguins were the
lowest form of bird an evolutionary
straggler inferior to the rest but this
could not be farther from the truth and
though their incredible adaptations have
allowed emperor penguins to conquer the
Antarctic a rapidly changing Global
Climate threatens their rign and might
turn their evolutionary Advantage into a
liability to understand what the future
may hold for these incredible Birds it's
important to ask how did they come to
rule such a frigid region and where do
they sit on the evolutionary tree how
are Emperor penguin built to survive the
Sea and the ice and how do they behave
to not only survive but to thrive in
such an extreme
[Music]
environment well before people
Associated penguins with acute stature
and comical waddling emperor penguins
were widely regarded by scientists as
the key to unlocking the secrets of
evolutionary theory in the early 20th
century the relatively fresh new theory
of evolution fascinated the scientific
world and inspired many to study animal
life and how it developed from this
surge of curiosity scientists noticed
that many animals also appeared to have
very similar looking embryonic stages
early in their development from this
curious observation biologist Ernst
hekel proposed recapitulation Theory as
a hypothesis for understanding The
evolutionary history of certain
organisms the theory suggested that the
embryos of more advanced life forms like
human embryos would always pass through
stages that looked like their
evolutionary ancestors that they would
go through phases of being a fish
amphibian reptile bird Etc until finally
turning into a human a recap of the
wider scale evolutionary process so why
did they believe penguins in particular
were the key to unlocking the secrets of
evolution because at the time Penguins
were considered to be the most primitive
bird in existence a bird that never
evolved the ability to fly scientists
thought that if they could decipher the
embryology of this most primitive of
birds they could more clearly see how
Aven organisms evolved from their
reptilian ancestors we now know that
this is not how it works like at all but
at the time they were quite convinced
and went to the ends of the Earth
literally to try to prove it it in 1910
a grand expedition began and a handful
of explorers set out to retrieve emperor
penguin eggs for science this would be
no small feat to catch an emperor
penguin egg would mean to Brave The
Frigid and rough terrain of the
Antarctic in the winter when it is often
pitch black The Voyage would later be
referred to by the Explorers as the
worst journey in the world and with good
reason at the time the expedition was
considered to be the longest period at
which humans were exposed to extreme
climate conditions what might have made
the journey even worse however was the
fact that its main objective the penguin
eggs turned out to not be so useful
recapitulation Theory began to be
discredited right around the time of the
Expedition as scientists began to
observe more varied embryologic
development patterns that didn't quite
align with H's Theory and even if the
recapitulation theory were true we now
know that penguins are far from the most
primitive birds in existence the
flightlessness of penguins which was
initially thought to be an ancestral
trait after having freshly evolved from
reptiles is actually a secondary evolved
trait the ancestor of penguins would
have been a flying bird similar to a
puffin or a corant but over time the
Penguins ancestor got better at swimming
and worse at flying and then around 60
million years ago
the penguin CLA split off losing their
ability to fly entirely and gaining what
researchers refer to as a hyp
specialized marine body plan the
transition from having a body built for
flying to one hyp specialized to survive
in a marine environment is one of the
greatest evolutionary transitions of all
time up there with when tetrapods first
stepped foot on land or when the
ancestors of whales took their steps
back into the sea but how could it
possibly be advantageous to give up the
ability to fly surely emperor penguins
could rule the Antarctic if they could
swim and fly soaring through its Skies
instead of waddling around on slippery
ice sheets but unfortunately in the
animal kingdom everything is a trade-off
and as Wings become more efficient for
flying they become less efficient for
swimming and vice versa to understand
this it's helpful to think about why
emperor penguins are considered the best
diving birds in the world unlike their
flying counterparts they have a reduced
wingspan have greater weight and larger
bones and even at a molecular level have
muscle contraction rates that are
optimized for low wingbeat frequencies
all adaptations that make flight
impossible the adaptations necessary for
flight simply go against the adaptations
necessary for swimming and when it comes
to swimming no other animal does it
quite like the emperor
penguin the body shape of an emperor
penguin lends itself to maneuvering
beneath the ice and while it might not
always look like it emperor penguins are
among the most elite swimmers on the
planet but there is so much more to
their underwater story than their big
boned streamlined body there are some
unexpected ways in which they maximize
their swimming efficiency things we
thought were reserved for our high-tech
ships and submarines one of these
adaptations was discovered when Marine
ecology researchers looking at footage
of emperor penguins ascending noted that
the birds were always followed by fine
bubbles that seemed to emerge from their
feathers in much the same way that an
underwater missile would leave a trail
of bubbles in its wake and with some
Torpedoes these bubbles are no accident
in the 1960s Engineers discovered that
in theory drag could be reduced on
underwater vessels if microbubbles were
injected on their surfaces covering them
in a thin film of air soon after the
Russian Navy figured out how to turn
this theoretical idea into reality they
developed a rocket powered torpedo that
could pump gas through a porous skin
that covered the torpedo it was capable
of traveling underwater at up to 100 m
per second more than twice as fast as
conventional Torpedoes a torpedo has to
overcome two two types of drag the first
is related to the weapon's shape and the
second is related to the way that water
clings to the surface of the object and
is drawn along with it slowing the
object down but if the torpedo is
enveloped in a layer of gas there will
be no direct contact between the object
and the water a layer of gas just a
fraction of a millimeter thick can
reduce skin friction by up to
40% could the bubbles observed on the
Penguin's bodies be doing the same thing
scientists observed that before emperor
penguins jump from the ice and plunge
into the water they first fluff up their
feathers trapping air in their plumage
then once the penguin decides it's time
to come up to breathe it will release
this trapped air from their body forming
a layer of fine bubbles that allows them
to shoot back up to the surface in
footage of penguins ascending it's easy
to see the bubble trails and if you
pause the footage you can even see the
bubble clouds that envelop most of the
body and obscure the tail and hind limbs
scientists also note that no air is
coming from the beak or Nars it emerges
from the plumage and the Boost they seem
to get from this is significant Penguins
descend and swim horizontally at around
2 m/s but they ascend with these Bubbles
at up to 6 m/ second and this is
critical because they need sufficient
speed to overcome gravity as they leap
out of the water and onto the sea ice
from this observation researchers
proposed that emperor penguins are
likely employing what they describe as
drag reduction by air release or more
simply air lubrication just like humans
use on ships and Torpedoes and apart
from this lubrication this bubble coat
might also offer other advantages for
example it's well known that air
lubrication can reduce the acoustic
signals of ships and the same might be
true for Emperor penguin and their
echolocating predators but as impressive
as this is emperor penguins aren't just
Adept at their heroic ascents they are
also the deepest diving birds in the
world this great feat has its advantages
for the Penguins Beyond just asserting
their rign as Emperor as the only Birds
capable of reaching such depths they are
virtually unchallenged in their claim
over the Abundant nutrient-dense and
relatively easy to catch prey like the
Atlantic silverfish that tends to
inhabit these benthic regions these
Dives can last almost 30 minutes to
manage these sustained deep Dives
emperor penguins are equipped with
physiological and cellular adaptations
that help them maximize oxygen use like
many air breathing divers the emperor
penguin diving reflex involves a massive
reduction in their heart rate that
allows many organs including the heart
itself to use up less oxygen one study
that attached El rods to Penguins during
diving revealed that for extremely deep
Dives heart rates can reach as low as
three beats per minute to complement
this diving reflex emperor penguins also
employ peripheral vasel constriction
here the birds are able to narrow blood
vessels to such a point that they can
effectively cut off certain muscles from
their overall blood circulation this
allows the blood and the oxygen it
carries to be distributed to more
important muscle groups and organs like
to the brain and the heart on a
molecular level the emperor penguin is
also exceptional at storing large
amounts of oxygen relative to its size
for example myoglobin A protein that
stores and supplies skeletal muscles
with oxygen is considerably elevated in
some muscles of emperor penguins
especially their pectoral muscles on the
other hand hemoglobin the protein mostly
found in the blood and responsible for
Distributing oxygen to the different
parts of the body has a consider
considerably higher affinity for oxygen
in the emperor penguin compared to other
birds this allows the blood to better
take up whatever oxygen is still present
in the lungs during hypoxic conditions
and better distribute this oxygen to
different parts of the penguin's body
but as incredible as this all is an
emperor penguin's ability to dive deep
in Antarctic Waters is only as useful as
their ability to keep
warm water temperatures in the Antarctic
hover below freezing at - 1.8 de C it
stays liquid only due to its high salt
content air temperatures can reach -40
or 50° C and winds often whip at speeds
as high as 144
kmph how any living creature can survive
here is almost Beyond Comprehension and
yet the emperor penguin thrives here and
their adaptations to do so are some of
the most fascinating in the animal
kingdom they owe 80 to 90% of their
Thermo regulation to the insulation
provided by their unique composition of
feathers to better appreciate this it's
important to understand the difference
between the four types of feathers the
Contour feather the pho plume the after
feather and the plumule contour feathers
are long stiff feathers that as their
name suggests provide a specific Contour
to the outer surface of the bird's body
body these feathers encase the body
keeping icy water out and protecting the
insulating layers below phop plumes are
almost microscopic feathers that are
likely used to sense the arrangement of
the contour feathers allowing the
Penguins to adjust the contour feathers
as needed to create a more hydrodynamic
shape in the water and then there are
the after feathers and plumules these
are the soft dowy feathers that make up
the insulation component of the plumage
after feathers are attached to Contour
feathers and plumules are attached
directly to the skin as you might have
guessed emperor penguins have a
considerably greater density of plumules
compared to contour feathers with a
recent study showing up to a fourfold
greater density of plumules compared to
contour feathers These Fine feathers
form a dense mat of insulation that
keeps emperor penguins warm and this
insulation remains intact and dry even
as Penguins continue their deep Dives
the high high density of these plumules
also provides support for the air
lubrication hypothesis mentioned earlier
as these fine feathers would produce the
fine bubble streams previously described
Beyond just extreme insulation to keep
heat from being drawn out into the
environment the plumage of emperor
penguins seems to grant them the
seemingly impossible ability to draw in
heat from a bitterly cold environment
when scientists pointed cameras at an
emperor penguin Colony they discovered
something almost paradoxical most of the
outer surface of the emperor penguin's
plumage was actually colder than the
surrounding Antarctic air this can
happen when the sky is clear and excess
heat is lost from the outer surface of
the body due to radiative Cooling and
because hot air naturally flows towards
areas of cooler temperatures emperor
penguins can suck in heat via convection
almost commanding the Heat and the
surrounding air towards themselves the
Penguins managed to do this without
actually feeling feeling the colder than
air plumage because the plumage itself
is a very poor thermal conductor
preventing any outward heat transfer
from the warmer inner surfaces of the
penguin to add an extra layer of warmth
emperor penguins also engage in what
researchers call social Thermo
regulation which basically means that
they huddle together in groups to share
and conserve body heat this isn't just a
random aggregation of cuddling though
research has shown that this huddling
behavior is a dynamic or organized
Network sensitive to environmental
changes such as air temperature wind
speeds and available sunlight in general
there appears to be a system of more
Loosely aggregated Penguins feeding
smaller huddles that appear to be in
Greater need of
warmth by now it's clear that the
emperor penguins have all the biological
tools to tolerate the challenges of a
harsh freezing climate however as we've
said they don't just tolerate these un
forgiving icy conditions they prefer it
this is probably best seen in their
preference to breed during the Antarctic
winter emperor penguins begin their
breeding Cycles when most other
Antarctic birds have already finished
theirs an emperor penguin's breeding
cycle begins around April when Antarctic
sea ice reforms and becomes thick enough
to support a breeding Colony at the
beginning of the cycle emperor penguins
of the same Colony return to the same
location they bred last year once all
huddled together the males engage in an
elaborate courtship ritual that involves
a mix of head bobbing swinging and
waddling with males sometimes even
competing for a mate when everyone is
partnered up emperor penguin pairs get
busy and each produce only a single egg
since the vast frigid expanse of the
Antarctic isn't exactly the best place
to set up a nest and there are no bushes
or branches the females hand over the
egg to their male partners who are
tasked with incubating the eggs on their
feet under a loose fold of featherless
skin called The Brood patch and because
the eggs must be kept warm at all times
the males do so for an astounding 4
month straight without any food at all
relying only on their body fat until the
chicks hatch around July it's been
speculated by some researchers that this
unusual Arrangement is brought about by
the fact that each pair of emperor
penguins has only one extremely valuable
egg to ensure that this single hope for
an offspring survives it's important
that the egg receives Round the Clock
protection and during an extreme winter
period when Predators such as leopard
seals and seabirds are not around then
once the egg hatches both Penguins raise
the chick into a fledgling until
December all these adaptations bring us
back to the big picture that emperor
penguins require sea ice throughout
their life cycle be it as a stable
Gathering Place for breeding and raising
chicks or as platforms for diving and
exploring the Antarctic Seas as it
stands today however the once
unquestioned reign of the Lords of
Antarctica appears to be quite literally
running on thin ice in 2022 satellite
imaging used to monitor emperor penguin
colonies showed a catastrophic breeding
failure due to the lowest sea ice ever
recorded in Antarctica that year these
dots show the locations of the five
emperor penguin colonies in this one
highly affected region remember that the
complete breeding cycle of emperor
penguins requires that sea ice remain
solid for a prolonged period of time if
this ice melts prematurely as it did in
20122 parent Penguins may be forced to
leave their premature chicks who have
yet to fully mature enough to come along
with their parents to more stable ice
while some emperor penguin colonies have
been documented to move towards more
stable ice shelves that are nearer to
land this may only be a temporary
solution if at all to a rapidly changing
climate that makes it difficult for
emperor penguins to continue their icy
way of life because of these unique
circumstances the emperor penguin has
become an emblematic species in
representing how climate change is
rapidly affecting Antarctic ecosystems
as The Narrative of the current climate
crisis unfolds there is something to be
said about how a bird we once thought
would provide us with all the secrets of
evolution is receiving interest once
more this time as an example of the
effects of our rapidly warming climate
but beyond being symbols of the climate
crisis something about these waddling
Birds just seems to resonate with so
many people maybe we see ourselves in
them just a bit upright clumsy kind of
chubby social creatures who just want to
hang out and cuddle I know I relate to a
lot of these but there's one thing in
particular about penguins that I deeply
relate to their need for a truly
ridiculous number of naps emperor
penguins take hundreds of naps
throughout the day at night for just a
few minutes at a time wherever they
happen to be standing chinstrap Penguins
take literally 10,000 naps per day
Penguins do this to make sure they stay
alert enough to run away from predators
if they need to humans do this because
they never really get enough sleep
because staring into a rectangle that
contains all the world's information is
more appealing than laying in a dark
room with all our own thoughts whatever
the reason for them a million naps a day
for Penguins is not really a problem for
me it kind of is I unfortunately got
stuff to do I got to teach you guys
about penguins and bugs and stuff so to
stay awake I do the most human thing
there is drink lots and lots of coffee
but also as a human I firmly believe I
deserve lots of little treats these
treats often mean going out and getting
myself an $8 latte don't get me wrong I
love this for me but $8 a day gets gets
to be a bit much so instead I sometimes
make myself coffee at home but the beans
from the grocery store that I have
stocked up in my cabinet are just not
that great they are questionably sourced
questionably roasted and questionably
aged thus pushing me towards more $8
lattes but now there's a new solution
thanks to this video's sponsor Trade
coffee trade is a subscription that
delivers fresh bags of coffee from over
55 of the country's top Indie Roasters
right to to your door and it's the best
way to help you do more in 2024 you need
trade if you want to hit the ground
running with your New Year's goals goals
such as not taking so many naps and
getting through your to-do list every
day and I absolutely love trade because
it helps me to make better coffee at
home I no longer need to go out for
little treats I can have them much more
cheaply and easily at home and the best
part is trade lets you experience coffee
that is curated just for you for example
I don't like dark roasts but I love
light roasts and I always want my coffee
to be whole bean so it stays fresher
longer but trade goes even deeper than
this trade Maps your specific
preferences to hundreds of different
coffee flavor profiles their technology
pairs you with the best coffees using
Art and Science marrying industry
expertise and machine learning it's been
so fun getting new recommendations and
trying new coffees that I never would
have been able to get before they even
have one from a roast called mother
tongue called the nebula roast of course
I had to try that one plus trade roasts
your coffee to order and delivers it
exactly when you need it it's so easy to
schedule an order so upgrade your
morning routine with better coffee right
now trade is offering real science
viewers a free bag of coffee with any
subscription at drink trade.com sreal
science that's drink trade.com sreal
science for a free bag of coffee with
any subscription purchase plus you'll be
supporting the channel by signing up
with that link so click the button on
the screen or the link in the
description to sign up
today